calvin what's up brother how can i help
well in a nutshell
um i'm afraid that my wife is falling
into a little bit of a postpartum
depression
okay and i'm really wondering how i as a
husband can walk
with her through this season hmm
so tell me what's going on
um she does have a history of depression
um we've been working through this since
really it was 2017 2018. okay um
we have we've been blessed with three
beautiful kids um
the first one dates only back to 2015 in
the summer
he actually was delivered at 36 weeks
through an emergency c-section
okay um we have some medical issues
there and so that was a very quick
uh we had to get him out but he's been
fine our second
came a very quick 18 months later um
you kind of chuckled there as though you
don't know how that happened
all right well you know all right so you
have 18 months later then the next kid
right right then the next kid came in
and she was literally born the week
before christmas
okay so this was december 16 we um
bring a new baby home everyone's excited
everyone's down for the holidays
and then here it comes january
everyone's left
i have to go back to work and now here
she is going into
january and february with two little
kids in her lap like okay well now what
right um so lots of exhaustion there and
then it just kind of
spiraled downhill from there over the
next couple years and then
um lots of just sleeping through the day
and
other issues like that um going into
2019
she actually contacted her ob that
spring and they actually gave her a like
an anxiety medication prescription
which helped um it did help
but then that summer we actually went
and saw a therapist i went with her for
the first one and she saw it
continued afterwards for a couple
sessions
we came out of that with a couple tools
in our belt
and we were progressing we made good
headway on it um she's remained on
medication ever since
um but she was in a good place now
fast forward to where we are now we were
just blessed with our third child
he was born in july but when we were in
the hospital we actually had a three-day
nicu stay
okay um and that that was just tough
um i've never seen her that emotionally
dark ever before
um the through lots of prayer
um and blessings from the lord we were
able to get home
everyone's fine um progressing as
expected
so definitely a blessing there um and
about three weeks ago she's telling me
she's in a good place
she's excited everything's going great
and then seven to ten days ago she
confides in me that we kind of
everything kind of took a left-hand turn
on us um she can find into me that she's
having weird
dreams one specific one that she told me
was
she dreamed that there was an accident
with a baby and
the anxiety of having to call
like our parents and explain what
happened it literally gave her a minor
panic attack
sure shortness of breath it just was
tough
um i have
since then she also she called back to
her ob and they increased her medication
again to get get through the season
um i've already pleaded with her to find
a therapist
um i do have to admit she didn't feel
that she connected very well to the one
we saw back in 2019 so
i'm pleading with her to find someone
that she could connect to
now um to talk with and develop some
tools
um let me ask you this let me interrupt
you here
so number one thanks for sharing that
that's that that arc of that narrative
is really helpful here
what kind of husband are you man how do
you solve problems
i'm a fixer um if a truck is broke i can
i can find the part i can fix it i can
so you can't you can't see this but on
my notes here i'm holding up
i wrote down problem solver
um and you sound like somebody who loves
their wife
more than life itself and you sound like
somebody who
loves their kids more than life itself
and what you're looking for desperately
is a set of solutions
an instruction manual on how to fix your
wife because she's hurting
and you want to make that pain go away
is that fair
that's that's absolutely right and and i
understand that i i can't fix it i i
can't there's not a broken bolt
somewhere
i can't it's not that easy that's right
brother that's right
so here's a couple things are going to
be really important for you and for her
navigating this this this sense this
water okay
the first thing is this um you can't be
the person who gives her
instructions you can't be the person who
gives her a set of
guidelines or operating rules or new
tools or tasks
okay your one job on planet earth and
you may have heard me say this over and
over again
and sometimes just hearing it directly
changes so i'm going to keep saying it
and keep saying it and keep saying it
and sometimes i'm saying it to myself
dude
is your job is not to fix your wife your
job is to be with her
okay she's going to learn a set of tools
she's going to work through this
depression and it could be all kinds of
stuff there's a couple things i wrote
down here that i'll
talk to you about but she needs you on a
daily basis when you wake up every
morning
before you all get out of bed before you
go try to solve the baby's challenges
and i know this is hard i've got a
little kid in my house too
i want you to hold her for two minutes
one full minute three minutes and tell
her some wackadoo
quack on the radio said to do this and
this is important that you get skin on
skin
contact not as something to solve but as
a person that you love
and that you can be with and then before
you get out of bed
i want you to look her directly in both
of her eyes
and say how can i love you today how was
last night and if she says i had these
really intrusive thoughts i had these
really hard dreams
i want you to say that sucks and i hate
that you're a great mom and i love you
don't say well remember last time and
have you checked in have you made this
call don't do that
she knows to make the calls she knows
that things aren't
super right she just needs somebody to
be with her and to listen okay
and so i want you to replay that three
or four times a day
how can i keep loving you today how can
i love you today and at the end of the
day i want you to hold both of her hands
and look her in the eye and say how did
today go
how was today and most of the time if
somebody's in the throes of
of um of this postpartum
hell it's not gonna go great and your
default setting when your wife says i'm
hurting
is to think who is the dudes knows i
need to go break
and what you're gonna have to do is look
her in the eye and say that sucks and i
hate that i want you to know that i love
you and you're a great mom
and that's that's that okay so
um and it's gonna be a it's gonna be a
spiritual discipline it's gonna be a
spiritual practice for you
to stop giving advice to stop trying to
fix her and just learn to slowly
be with her okay if she's got a history
of depression so if she had struggled
with depression so i'm backing out a
little bit she struggled with depression
before kid number one
did she have that in her teenage years
or during college that kind of stuff
not that i'm aware of okay um i was with
her through college but i didn't really
see the tendencies it really didn't
start coming in okay i'm
super prevalent until the 2018 time so
i'm speaking into something that i can't
experience because i'm a guy
but i've read about this and i've heard
it anecdotally from
from important women in my life when you
are raced off to an emergency c-section
there is this notion that my body failed
that my body didn't work the way it was
supposed to
women who struggle with infertility
challenges there's this existential
crisis that goes deep into your core
into their core which is
i was put here on earth for one thing
and my body's not doing that one thing
and often guys can't understand the
depth of that trauma how much that
weighs on somebody
and so getting rushed to the hospital
and have to and having to be saved by
doctors by having a baby
cut out of you there's something that
sits in your soul that says my body is
supposed to do one thing
and it didn't do it and that can really
wreak havoc on folks
the second thing is after after
emergency c-sections you get all kinds
of
hormonal and and
biological responses that aren't i don't
say aren't normal because c-sections
have become normal but
um it just it's playing whack-a-mole
with hormones and with body chemicals
and stuff
so calling an ob gyn making sure she's
to connect with her doctor is critical
and important
and getting connected with a therapist
that's going to help being on meds
forever i don't think that's a great
solution
so you've got to find someone who can
help with hormone regulation who can
help with diet all those kind of things
and again it goes back to something that
you mentioned that's magic is
finding somebody that you can that you
trust that she feels comfortable with
that she can feel like she can be in a
relationship with
another thing is this notion of
a woman's body becomes a it becomes a
machine
right when you've got two little kids
and then a third one you're just
an exhausted tractor everybody's using
you for a thing right everyone wants you
to accomplish these set of tasks
i got to feed this kid i got to change
this kid i've got to clean this thing
i got to cycle and repeat i'm going to
sleep two hours i'm going to get up and
feed
and then you just it again it's an
exhaustion that
many men can't understand because it
gets into your soul
and it's countered with this narrative
that these are supposed to be so lovely
and wonderful and what great times and
right and so you got this messaging
going into your head these stories that
we're telling ourselves
and it doesn't play out that way in real
life um and then the final thing is this
i can't put my head in the heart of a
woman who's been through
heavy postpartum who struggled with this
whose body didn't work the way
that they had drawn it up the way that
the stories
had been told it was going to work with
a an emergency c-section
and all of a sudden your baby's born
baby number three you've been down this
road and then you've got this emergency
nike stay
that is a that's a recipe for all kinds
of existential challenges
for biological responses stress
responses hormone responses are going to
be flying all over the place so
you're just going to be in a hard hard
place if her doctor's response is well
let's just crank up more meds let's just
crank up more meds let's just crank up
more meds
i want to challenge her i'm going to
challenge you
to get connected to another doctor that
you trust get to neck connected to
a probably a team probably a team of
medical professional a psychological
professional who's going to walk you
through this
and they are going to be the ones that
give her tools they're going to be the
ones that
get feedback from her and support from
her and you're going to be the one who
walks alongside
and is just serves as somebody who is
with her who is holding her arms up when
she's exhausted
who is supporting her and loving her and
your relationship is going to continue
to fuse
closer and closer together you can't fix
her brother
you can be with her and you can love her
and i know for most guys when i just
said that
that is what love is is fixing and if i
can
if i can shake every dude listening to
this out there and let him know your
wife
is not a puzzle to solve and she is not
an engine to fix
she is someone to love and be with let
doctors and
psychologists and counselors be folks
who give new tools
and then you all grow together man hey
listen brother calvin
i'm i'm thinking about you and your wife
she needs to get with the right
professionals
and i'm gonna man i say this over and
over on the show
just an endless we'll just keep up in
the meds that's not a solution long term
um that's not a solution long term my
prayer is that your wife will go sit
down with somebody and say i want to
learn to make peace with my body
i want to learn to make peace with my
hormones and i want to learn to make
peace with my
own emotional and physical and
psychological state and so i want
someone to
give me some some tools and i want to
practice moving forward
let me know how this goes i want you to
her to find a therapist that works for
her that loves her
and it's probably not going to help for
you to keep beating her on the head with
that one dude
is maybe a recommendation here and there
you start seeing somebody and let her
know hey i'm going to talk to somebody
because i want to love and support you
the best i can
and maybe she'll follow that lead there
and i hope she's going to get with folks
who can walk alongside her professionals
so
thanks brother for the call